breathing from podcast Ville it's
Thursday the 21st of February before we
get this party started I want to talk to
you about some wanna talk to you about
quick clip is one of the most important
things we do for our health every day is
brushing our teeth believe it or not yet
most of us don't do it properly quip is
a better electric toothbrush created by
dentists and designers quip was designed
to make brushing your teeth more simple
affordable and even enjoyable you know
why I love quip to be honest I love
travelling with it and I love the timer
on each side it's tremendous so do me a
favor
I love quit and I want you to love him
too they're backed by over 20,000 dental
professionals and quip starts in just
twenty five hours if you go to get quick
calm slash Joey right now you'll get
your first refill pack for free with the
quip electric toothbrush okay listen
there's nothing not to like that it's
got a built-in two-minute timer that
pulses is every 30 seconds to remind you
when to switch sides what was was last I
met a toothbrush like that this is as
good as it gets to me a favor go to get
quick calm slash joy right now and
you're gonna get your first refill pack
for free with wit equipped electric
toothbrush that's your first refill pack
for free with WEP get quick calm slash
Joey the church is also brought to you
by on it when it comes to supplements
honors the way to go okay I can't do
none for you with the club backs or the
kettlebells but so much is alpha brain
shroom tech mushroom sport I'm here for
you go to John it calm right now impress
in church boom and get 10% off take this
[ __ ] muley I Lisa dick in this
[ __ ] you got the Christ killer
it's Thursday morning whatever you need
to do you got a do I'm 56 and I'm still
slinging dick alright Matt is 56 is
still swinging dick it's official
are we what's the story what's the haps
oh man
justice Smollett is the haps making
black people look bad all over the
country man said no I ain't gay don't
bleep with the same [ __ ] time
and Nigeria Nigeria - it was - not Jade
immigrants that he lets in jail that
stiva the story up he's gonna come back
with he didn't she didn't have to go to
the police on Tuesday or Monday
he didn't have to show up on Monday
because the holiday boy I don't think is
enjoying the Presidents Day no they they
arrested those two Nigerian guys and
then they left like they completely let
them go in like three hours
that's a quickest investigate I've never
heard of it they told the story it was
like look we we not having to go to jail
but they was already arrested David are
arrested sit in jail and Jesse out that
time I fall I fall I follow who who did
he fight
he paid us a lot was on the show
he use what What did he say
so he's not he's not going to come he
rescued us I need to talk to the
authorities didn't over text what he
didn't want to give him the phone yeah
that was when I knew something was up
you can't say nothing no more because in
the black community come after you and
the gay community come after you but I
mean my wife my wife of vouch we were
talking about at the NI before dinner
something else not right here yeah and
his beaten wasn't that severe his face
wasn't that beat-up
yo yeah like a little bit slap and you
know he made up a thing they put a rope
around his neck and they with Trump
people know that he's loose
Joe you gotta give what he said he said
they put a noose around his neck and all
I wanted to know who is walking around
with a noose at Chicago and took like in
the morning and negative 25 coming from
a former person that used to rob people
I promise you I'm nothing to rob you I'm
not gues robbing nobody and goddamn
negative 25 I need to know but you have
a double bag of your legal money that I
can take for you okay somehow no you
talk this over the last thing I Nigerian
knows how to do is tie your knot it
especially a [ __ ] news okay the last
thing a brother even [ __ ] her this rope
you can't show up to a brother
thinking all nervously [ __ ] so its
mission line yes news no come on telling
you dog I mean they give they don't know
how to tie knots like people when you
that you never seen a black boy scout no
they don't like the nut test not yet
never seen a black in the Boy Scouts
once they start buying those nuts that's
racist
we don't wanna sail it not that's what
they hire says the Swift and [ __ ] you'll
never see a black boy scout you'll never
see mr. Williams let this kid be a Boy
Scout you know there's a racist in
training even though thousand of we go
I'm gonna go with joint you shouldn't be
a boy a black boy scout you've never
seen a black boy scout
they're either gay or KKK those little
kids maybe they come out to be gay at
KKK either the [ __ ] truth we know
[ __ ] I'm in the muffler Sandusky's and
they send them out into the wilderness
what you think is gonna happen for these
poor kids surviving they moved to Santa
Monica Boulevard you'll never see a
black boys got good go up the picture of
the [ __ ] Boy Scout
see if you ever see a Boy Scout it's in
their [ __ ] DNA to do that [ __ ] it's a
job witnesses don't stand up for the
flag black people don't want to know
nothing about that [ __ ] ain't no black
boys guys man the thing was when he said
that he went home and left the noose
around his neck for 42 minutes until the
police got there and my mind was like
wait a minute
was the was the noose was the noose oh
[ __ ] tight I was it was it wasn't a
loose loose or what kind of loose was
that you got a right to get there Nick
still waiting this is not goes this [ __ ]
I'm like what the [ __ ] we got in this
office the cops are on their way they're
kicking the [ __ ]
George throwing stuff under the table
small news this I'm away for the police
I'm waiting for the authorities to get
here to show them the evidence of the
noose being tied around my neck that was
a dumb [ __ ] man they need to see
somebody bleach on why would you have
the whole [ __ ] story was just [ __ ]
stupid it's just like this arm Virginia
thing they do being in blackface it was
the funniest thing I've ever heard in my
life
yeah he started explaining himself and
got himself deeper in the hole I went to
a Michael Jackson one time and then the
reporter second you move walk for his
right now
he looked around and his wife was like
his wife was like nah nothing [ __ ]
been that movie [ __ ] moonwalk they'll
throw you under the prison moonwalk
Hey he said he'd surrender yet ya know
and the number two got it shakes up
twice and he shitness rindy like hey I
was like no I would dysentery then I was
23 I was a dumb [ __ ] I didn't know it
like hope the people blank you was like
a first lady like get the [ __ ] out it
they may realize like no no wait a
minute
now we alright with that that's not
really tearing the scab off of racism a
lot of other she did tear the scam but
what about that was the funniest thing
ever because if he retire if he stepped
down the dude was gonna take his place
got his dick sucked two days before and
now another chick came out and said he
raped her again dude dude number three
why do said I don't want the job I gotta
be honest with you back in 1960 I went
to a Halloween party I put blackface on
he kicked copped even before the priest
came up yeah so that [ __ ] hysterical
is that that is the funniest thing I've
ever seen that night when they were like
whoa there's the problem
there must be easy to find yeah it's
like it's like half of the Senate in
most of the house should have they
[ __ ] yearbooks own dick cuz most of
them went to these Ivy League college
they do did have a tradition to doing
blackface parties so they might wanna
everybody might wanna check they goddamn
tree at this point but the lieutenant
governor this was the goddamn funny and
[ __ ] in the world to me
I was like okay so the lady said one
lady said I just want to say that he
raped me and I don't want to say [ __ ]
else I don't need no interview just know
he raped me don't ask me no more
questions
when don't take I ain't give you no time
another [ __ ] we're gonna talk about it
we are impeaching him wait a minute wait
wait so you want to testify at an
impeachment hearing but you don't want
to testify in Criminal Court like no I
don't need no criminal is his job but I
don't want him to go to jail and then is
my thing as me and I hate when I hate
with other me and come out [ __ ]
pandering [ __ ] [ __ ] well I find Huck
I find when she's saying credible I find
what you saying being so a bunch of
[ __ ] because one thing is out of all
the muscles that I have on my body
the one muscle that I don't want in your
mouth if I'm forcing you to do it here's
my dick that's what I don't want because
everybody if you if you put up a fight
everybody gonna know that you putting up
a fight because I'm gonna scream the
loudest let a woman bite down your dick
head cuz she don't want suck your dick
oh no you forced me to do this I don't
want to be ready everybody gonna know
why she anybody's dick why why did you
blame another person on a basketball
play the same school do for raping you
as well that's Sonny you got Rick at the
ED my two people at the same school and
you still graduated you're bad
[ __ ] and you still took a
yearbook picture [ __ ] I can't get you
can't I can't get into to racial
skirmishes at Heights do it they believe
her about the rape about the basketball
player one away
no it went away because she had all type
of messages about how she said she's
gonna make [ __ ] worse in his life he's
alright I make your life worse because
she like she don't like to be broke away
she gotta [ __ ] break up his shoes you
break over her off sudden you [ __ ]
raped her and then the lady the first
one um wait a minute aren't you
auditioning you work for the District
Attorney's Office you
work for a woman shelter no batter each
other so why you never told nobody this
man right you at all but you had other
interviews about things of such nature
but you never brought him up so you
saying the child on a secure feel you
said this happened at the Democratic
convention and you went up to a floor
with him that has fans all over the
goddamn floor because they're secured
other Democratic people that's on the
floor you own the floor with Fayette
that that's coming and going as a person
that did on some small-scale [ __ ] I used
to be the comic with the Texans I flew
on the plane with Texas have you ever
heard of an NFL player raping a girl on
the floor on the team floor you can't
it's a person it's [ __ ] cops up there
local cops from that city would ever see
they planning that's on the floor
guarding the elevators so people can't
get up and press can't get up and if any
woman come on that floor you was brought
up there by a player and if you left the
police saw you they saw you going and
coming just like at the Democrats it
they saw our coming going and coming
so she was raped she would have told one
of the cops on the walk down that this
brother just raped they would have
sucked it's the [ __ ] fans I every
inch of this but it's like it's like I'd
never believe the plan ran into the
Pentagon the Pentagon got cameras every
inch of [ __ ] so you gonna tell
me that a plane ran into the goddamn
Pentagon and we don't ain't no it's not
a napkin a wheel a screw or fin found
another that sort of playing the scripts
[ __ ] be disintegrated into the wallet
Pentagon a there's no pictures of [ __ ]
coming going it doesn't it it can't make
sense when the fans are on the floor so
he's like what type of [ __ ] mind
could show he got where you don't look
the shuffle you don't look great
you ain't say nothing you know like on
the flow with the fan damn that's deep
but don't nobody want to file criminal
charges they just want him impeached but
no criminal charges because the criminal
charges to take care of getting the
beach if he get found guilty he can't be
lieutenant governor in jail the job has
to go up for sale he gave me like I
don't know well I'm found guilty but I'm
still the [ __ ] lieutenant governor it
doesn't happen like that so why don't
they want to file criminal charges they
all under the they are other the statute
of limitation all of them the two scary
[ __ ] world out there bro the Senate
were that somebody could wake up
tomorrow morning and say least I had
with him was wouldn't yet the fourth
wall last night on the way home he tried
to [ __ ] me in the ass you know and I'll
call legally what happened last night
and I never tried to [ __ ] her in the ass
I she asked me for a ride home
I told her I couldn't because she was
kind of scary and this is the kind of
[ __ ] that happens in real life
this is the kind of [ __ ] that could
happen and did you go for a rape kit no
because I was scared
Lee was gonna beat me up you know
meanwhile you know this is it this is
our map this is our [ __ ] we've we've
you know but then again if smoke that's
fine if it didn't happen you're
exonerate yes but still it's still
impeaches by your mom don't get
exaggerated you get you get the [ __ ]
small print behind obituaries that you
win eight when they accused you you get
the front page you are accused of these
allegations but when you get exonerated
you are behind you behind the obituaries
in small print in cursive a writer
should encourage suit in the paper like
was your name of the paper you got
arrested no I was hoping it wasn't no my
name's on the paper
I lived in bold with my name yesterday
but it changed the game being one should
implement on the paper once people read
something instead of hearing it it
really scares people people just stayed
clear of me once your name comes on the
paper Wow
the idea I never wanted to be in the
paint no not like I'm not like that I
will I wanted to be in print then I was
out here being a street pharmaceutical
rep yeah but I'm embracing it now now um
you know I try not to tell
stories I was getting a little irritated
with people thought that that's all I
did might you know it took me a while to
sell even tell the prison story so and
then I just start embracing it in I go
[ __ ] it I'm I'm gonna just do the story
and if he won't ask me questions I'll
talk about it but it's the it's the
questions that people ask you that piss
you off a little bit like this is the
number one question that pisses me off
so were you um did you um find humor in
jail to protect yourself and then I say
well what did you get that from
like what make you think that that can
happen um a kid in the play moving house
party two people have believed that [ __ ]
since how since it was say the house
party to when that man sitting in jail
kids and out in the jail cell with him
and and he said well do you gotta do
Richard Brown said he did where's your
pricing when he was in jail he was
gentle joke to keep they mind keep him
laughing to keep their mind off his
booty
now when the [ __ ] was Richard Pryor ever
in jail
never so the [ __ ] can't be true but he
was saying the movie so that's what
people think and then I asked a question
if I was standing here at six foot three
six four four about 280 would you add
and I said I'm a comic same thing and I
did it start in jail not I said would
you ask me that same question would you
say did you start doing comedy in
general particular you wouldn't think
you wouldn't you wouldn't think to say
this [ __ ] to me at all but you're
looking at um real life you're looking
at a welterweight 140 pounds 145 pounds
you looking at a welterweight and you
think that I need to tell be humorous in
order to protect myself you looking at
let me tell you I'm the same size as
Bernard Hopkins Floyd Mayweather um in
Marvelous Marvin Hagler Sugar Ray
Leonard and sweet beat Pannell wick I'm
the same [ __ ] size as them I'm
the same size packet
so I asked like what in people's mind
make you think that I got to be humorous
in order to protect myself what about me
that you didn't think that I could
protect myself but I get it it's some of
the stories that I'm telling now that in
prison that you real not have to be
super aggressive even when you feel like
the [ __ ] is not necessary because you
still an intelligent person some I ask
you a question
they don't you didn't answer aggressive
enough for you so they want to put you
in a tank you know protect your cousin
Tang I don't need to be in here I don't
even know the [ __ ] this is to not wanna
be my lord disease so now I got to beat
somebody up in here for you to move me
out of here because I'm saying this
thing why I supposed to be but what
about me died and I didn't say it what
you wanted me to say do you think you
can defend yourself in a man time Mattel
would you what did you want me to say oh
[ __ ] yeah i'ma kill everybody in here
what did you want me to say just like
now as a grown man what do you want me
to be like I don't want to be extra
aggressive because when I am being extra
aggressive then I say to [ __ ] like that
I probably the only in my mind and I'm
gonna run with other people I'm like you
know I'm probably the only person in
Iran that actually took somebody's
breath from them but they don't know
what they don't breathe no more I'm
probably the only person I'm like I'm
the probably the only person here that's
that's thinking about stabbing multiple
people in here if something goes well
I'm probably the only person here that's
that's fixing my mind for problems at
this goddamn gala we had a gala and in
my mind something something can happen I
gotta be able to you know be able to
maneuver out of this I'm probably the
only person with these [ __ ] defects
in my in my brain because of the
situations that I've been in
incarcerated and I've always protected
myself in there but don't ask me no
[ __ ] stupid-ass questions like did
did I use us cuz ain't no [ __ ] stage
in there ain't no way it's a comedy
program
then I was a [ __ ] humorous sarcastic
dude just like I am gonna say he's now
so it's no stage and ain't no [ __ ]
time eight o'clock y'all know I leave
doing a show at 8:00 it was it wasn't
like that
but people ask you these [ __ ]
[ __ ] ask questions I can see if
somebody asked you like for me did humor
I knew six months before I got sentenced
I was going to jail I didn't want to
accept it I thought I was only going
there my cute ass and humor the [ __ ]
judge at the sentencing that's what I
thought my attorney had done everything
he cleared did a great job
I plea bargains but I kept pushing the
trial back to the sentencing day until
one day they called out of the blue and
said the judge says he wants to get this
off his docket and then I came to
materiality I was swimming I was hitting
the bag I was riding the bike I was
preparing myself mentally I didn't
accept that I was in prison for about a
week for about a week you don't accept
it after you get sentenced five days
four days and for four days you beating
yourself up and then you just let go and
breathe and say I'm gonna put this in
God's hands and I'm just gonna have the
best time I can in here did I use humor
to make my time go easy and [ __ ] yet my
doing stand-up no in my head you know
you gotta watch what you say in there
you gotta walk a certain way in there
you gotta keep your eyes a certain way
you gotta you can't let a mother [ __ ]
get away with zero point zero not zero
point zero does that come back into my
life from time to time yeah I don't let
him [ __ ] go past point [ __ ]
zero point that he nobody understands
that unless you're in it couple weeks
ago I went to New York my wife and kid I
took the ferry over to New York did my
[ __ ] in New York what to take the ferry
back bro you told me Holly
Lee you know me
come on ball no but I keep my mouth shut
I'm standing on the [ __ ] line
alley with my daughter in my right hand
there's maybe a foot between me or some
lady and some dude just cuts right in
and walks past me as he was walking
right here Lee
I want to write back to 1987 in that
prison and I elbow shouldered him and he
went and he looked at me like excuse me
he looked at me for a second and he goes
excuse me and then he stepped back he
just kept looking at me and I kept
looking at him and we gave ourselves
about a minute like was there a problem
I like going my darling was there a
problem
and he goes there's no problem when the
ferry can be on the ferry I got back
that I sat down I apologized to my wife
but I got that from prison yeah not 0
not 0 not 0 before it even comes out of
your mouth not 0 that's how I was raised
that's how men were when I was growing
up not 0 as 0 so we mean when people ask
me the questions I know it wasn't like
it XYZ then you ask me notes to play a
question so now then it clicks yo man
you want a bunch of cliche [ __ ] you
which one you want me to rewrite the
movie script that you got in your
[ __ ] locker that's all your laptop or
something that you say you probably for
dumbass answers that you know and that's
that's that mentality of that prison
mentality is [ __ ] you can't let
nobody get away with a gangster not like
you you can't say no slick [ __ ] and me
not respond like what like I don't let
you get past nothing now I should you
know as you know over the years I let
people I love people I arm down I put my
guard down just to let them you don't
let them you have to just to let to see
how far they didn't take a push to see
how crazy they [ __ ] really are in
their mind
I put the guard down and the shield and
I'm trying I'm trying to be this
loosey goosey type of person and the
[ __ ] just result right back because you
can't top you've like y'all you know
something [ __ ] I don't want to be this
person I don't want to be I don't want
to be carefree to this [ __ ] comes with a
lot with a lot man there's no like in
his business man so many masu any
[ __ ] mistake you make you know like
the Kevin [ __ ] with it with the Oscars I
like that with some corny [ __ ] like you
who sat down and went back through all
them [ __ ] tweets and [ __ ] define it's
like it's like they try not to give
people you know what they deserve do the
[ __ ] language man I has a comic man
we say what we want to say give or take
you know good or bad said something
before did you get insulted when I
sitting on black people in the Boy
Scouts not at all
no people are gonna find that insulting
yeah and it's not insulting to me at all
I think it's a joke and it's true I
wasn't a boy I was only blowing about
two weeks not one black dude signed up
and it was in the [ __ ] Bronx okay not
one black dude signed up they didn't
have the heart I mean mr. Williams told
Jasper in front of me he ain't gonna be
no more [ __ ] Cub Scout because I was
a Cub Scout first I didn't like it
either but my point is that there's
people out there looking for that now
dead guys like you and I understand the
one thing second chances are on
[ __ ] so okay now a lot of people
understand the second chance concept in
this country second chances got me to
where I'm going
okay got me here got you here so how did
you feel a couple months ago let's just
talk about that when they were going
after that [ __ ] Judge for
covering the chicks mouth in college all
right [ __ ] been a judge for 30
years whatever the [ __ ] he is never got
in trouble again and you mean to tell me
you're gonna come now to talk to me
about something me did in 1982 then he
covered some chicks month which is all
[ __ ] was all political [ __ ] if you
understand the nitty gritty dirty
politics that's going on in this country
you'll understand what's going on now
where three women came out
spreaded the one he raped the one at
Harvard or Yale or ever the [ __ ] he went
to but the main one with the glasses see
Cavanaugh Cavanaugh that was there
Cavanaugh but what they were really mad
about was some abortion bill that he was
signing or something like that the same
thing with this governor in Virginia
that's all who is signing some abortion
bill what came out about um the lady
with the glasses crystal did it come out
that she was saying things Rosalyn I
can't they can't prove it either way I
wasn't can't see the the the only thing
that got me with her was this I don't
know how when somebody telling the story
and they correct a insignificant part a
part that was [ __ ] very insignificant
oh okay let me correct that I had on
some on shoes and the strings were green
I didn't want you to think the shoes
were orange correct you had that right
but you said the strings were black no
the strings were green and then go on oh
I don't remember that you you are
correct she was doing the technical [ __ ]
that I find to be credible he was doing
the imma try to talk louder then
everybody to make you believe me now do
I think he did it
my husband you your young white kid
drinking [ __ ] beer you drunk you
first of all your white boy drinking
beer and a goddamn Clubhouse underage I
know goddamn well you did something I've
been I've been to school with white boys
drunk I know a thousand of them get
drunk and do all type of [ __ ] weird
ass [ __ ] thousand of them so nine times
of the ten you party it's like it's like
trying to say you do black dude and you
you was full of [ __ ] Hennessey and
you didn't cuts nobody out so wait a
minute you were full of Hennessey and
you didn't say one curse word Oh you's a
[ __ ] life you just goddamn like
Hennessey make you curse that's that's
that's in the bottle but it's like you
poured drink they got curse words in the
liquor man it doesn't it doesn't
trans my so I knew I don't I just didn't
like him as his the whole [ __ ] me
there's the meaning we like well it's
like yo you are lying
well he's uh what's that [ __ ] they
called he had that bitter air to him
that of affluenza right yeah you can see
the one thing about to do and Stafford
say to do this Stafford range the girl
swimming the judge sentenced him to
apologize I said I don't want he said
the man said he didn't want to ruin his
life
well you [ __ ] want to ruin mine when
I was a drug deal at nineteen you dare
you try to throw all the time at me he
people man some of this [ __ ] I just
don't I don't get like cops shooting
unarmed people and not getting nothing
happening to him
that's some [ __ ] weird ass [ __ ] like
anytime should go awry and you the
responsible person you're the one that's
supposed to be the responsible person
that's like this is this is your podcast
it's like me coming in and decide not to
talk about nothing to [ __ ] that you want
to talk about and then somebody said
well Joey I leave this being difficult
in that podcast and you know it uses
letting him talk about well I couldn't I
couldn't control the conversation right
but you wouldn't say that you like you
know that [ __ ]
Chuck is you care I kept turning to [ __ ]
back to where it was bug you know is you
not gonna let me come in just do what
the [ __ ] I want to do on your podcast in
saying it's like so I never get people
saying that they didn't have any control
over something you had some sort of
control some type of authoritative
control over as a as a cop you're
professional you're not supposed to have
the same temperament and some regular as
Joe on the street you supposed to be
able to be more tolerable of anything
because you are a professional that's
trained in it if you I've seen a cop I'm
cursing saying um he's looking at me and
asked me straight up are you done no I
ain't [ __ ] done everything I
said risk what I want
hey so you done now here's the thing are
we being a cop has changed dramatically
yeah the 30 years okay when I was a
young kid if I li grew up in North
Hollywood he would become a North
Hollywood cop
which means you got roots in the
community you know all the knickknacks
of the community are and now you're the
beat cop you're the low man on the totem
pole
the beat cop is the biggest crime
deterrent there is because I know you're
gonna be back in 43 minutes whatever I
gotta do has got to be done in 43
minutes now that guy becomes a detective
in North Hollywood and so on and so
forth and so on well he knows the
streets now these cops leaves the nice
guy because it became a cop okay get me
after high school goes to college gets
out of college he doesn't know what he
wants to do he could become a cop what
if you know yeah you could train all you
want as shooting a [ __ ] target but
unless you know the game unless you know
what man half the people of the dying
shouldn't be dying they should all be
getting shot in the leg I'll eat poses a
threat to me and he's got a knife I'm
not gonna shoot him in the head I'm
gonna shoot him in the goddamn pinky toe
like Eddie Murphy shot the chick in the
belly No and put you down so will I do
that under pressure will I do that when
there's police car lights can you do
that when there's [ __ ] cameras out
and everybody got a [ __ ] camera
you know nothing is right now if I see
you if I get out of my police car and
you're doing this with a [ __ ] knife
you're not coming at me with the knife
you know you're just doing like this
there's mental health issue there's a
thousand things
what's wrong with shooting a
[ __ ] in the leg what's wrong -
taser
okay the tased is wrong with fat's out
going through so people are panicking
you know you go for your cop though
we've seen we've seen crimes that they
should put the cops under the prison
that dude who shot that black dude
[ __ ] head at the top in the car in
the car that's the worst that stuff
should have been put under the jail the
dude a couple weeks ago it on the mall
in Texas he pulled out his gun and they
shot him I can't I don't know if I'm a
cop I'm running in I hear people yelling
and screaming this confusion on I look
and I see a brother taking out a gun put
it down you know put it down what if
that put it down he just turns at me I
don't know if he's I don't know if he's
military training I don't know what the
[ __ ] is so there's there's a we
can we're not there in Texas was crazy
it ethic I don't understand cops in
Texas when you know a lot of people have
gun licenses you going in yeah are you
going in fire on the white guys that you
see in with guns and that's the crazy
[ __ ] because these are the mass shooters
I'm still confused on how in the [ __ ]
are we even considered dangerous what's
the last thing a black person done name
it
Jesse [ __ ] Smollett we lied and
said this bubble got attacked that's it
what's the last [ __ ] violent
crime that we have done we're gonna
sniper like 15 years ago remember that
guy that [ __ ] 15 years ago the
DC sniper hey man we we don't have no
the lot we ain't got no [ __ ] goddamn
we kidnapped no whole bunch of [ __ ]
people we we don't have no drug routes
and then my brother rapped about our
limb we don't have what god damn there's
only thing we've done with head Obama
that's it we ain't done the
[ __ ] thing how are we still the
number one [ __ ] predator big sixteen
hundred mass shootings we have done none
of them not one not even a tan
[ __ ] done it not even a tan one
every time there's a mass shooting every
black person America goes whoa we ain't
getting the blame for that [ __ ]
right that is these crazy white people
now I get it I get it how much of it do
you think of is it is it race versus
economics like because that's what
always so shows to me to my core
the guy who has money like the affluenza
is gonna get away with it
it doesn't believe in matter like the
race matters maybe a little bit it I
don't in mass shootings I don't know how
the race would matter and that when it's
when it's like yo it's a it's a weird I
don't know what the [ __ ] matters no more
because it's so many unarmed unarmed
african-american people getting shot
versus you go in and shoot okay the mass
shooting up in the church right he's
shot nine elderly people he killed nine
elderly people how in the [ __ ] did you
do you arrest him and make sure that he
has some neat yeah and every every mass
shooting now when it's when it's a
person they know who they were they
going up Doug they make sure that they
go in and they make sure they say it all
the time you go back and you listen to
it we arrested the same there with no
incidents they make sure they said that
with no incident so how [ __ ] is this
man selling CDs in front of a store how
did he as he did how is I don't
understand and but then you want to say
this man in blackface ripping off the
[ __ ] scab and reminding us of slavery
and racism minutes cuz you know that's
not the [ __ ] scab that's being ripped
off by blackface I'm well aware of what
happens in blackface but I'm not
understanding the why so many like you
say you got this you got this this dude
this country dude from Alabama or some
small town in Texas in some small area
with just predominate he just all him
he's ever seen then you put him in a to
patrol the neighborhood of people that
he never really dealt with evidence guys
know stalking him and he has no idea
that because I'm talking loud I'm not
[ __ ] man I'm just talking loud I'm not
being aggressive because I'm doing this
Sato
you have no [ __ ] training to be
around it's like somebody listening to
my aunt and my uncle talk to each other
hey man each other cuz the way they
telling each other no she don't tell him
[ __ ] [ __ ] of all time he gonna say right
back bring your ass here do you shut the
[ __ ] up soggy bread coming now they not
manage to that's love that's affection
if I use it in and then but in if you
don't know that you looking at on the
outside look at my god it's [ __ ] that
why why did he tell each other like that
well you know we handle think we have a
things a lot a lot different according
to you know we roll up on yeah who were
rolling up on well what you know a lot
of people don't you know listen I was
out of Rogen's last month we were
talking and I told them what Harvey
wasn't into Harvey's gonna get himself
out of this we're criminals
we know the plan I got a plan I used to
just go to court just to watch court
when I was a kid you know I enjoyed it I
really do enjoy the judicial process
people gonna court
[ __ ] proving that they're guilty I
love all that [ __ ] I eat that [ __ ] up
alive I knew what he was in the deal I
know exactly what he was gonna do
Cosby didn't do it Cosby got more money
than [ __ ] guy Cosby she got three
white chicks to go on they represent
they all are the angry black sister I
found the hole bob was cousin I found
that word on how he got hard he in jail
got Cosby got cheap on the arm on his
attorneys yeah you know all that money
in the world [ __ ] fire the people who
got you the hung jury he walked in there
with another jury but then on the other
side of that did you know that um his
wife Camille and had um wrote I wrote
this letter [ __ ] bad mouth and the arm
the judge like really talking [ __ ] about
the judge and a judge didn't respond and
say nothing but then the new trial come
the judge people don't realize he let he
left five
who had nothing to do with my phone case
testify against Kyle he allowed he
allowed their testimony five women had
nothing to do with this [ __ ]
not a goddamn thing the judge like you
what you don't do you in the trial we
know this you don't talk [ __ ] about the
judge no that's what you get that's the
name I'm [ __ ] that you don't talk
[ __ ] the judge you don't want to say but
nothing bad about the bailiffs there cuz
a baby knowing the bailiffs kin-kee I
remember um missing the court date and
the bailiff um on my behalf spoke up for
me no judge he's been here he's been
here every other time I don't what is
calling a continuance
yo he'll turn you on your the bond or
the bond and if they didn't take my barn
they let me keep my bond just had to
show back up and [ __ ] your arm the
bailiffs man the bailiffs looked out you
gotta know you gotta know the people in
the court system man it ain't just about
that's if you don't know who in then who
in there and then I got [ __ ] wait
it's a lot of people in that room they
gotta wait other than your attorney
because your attorney is only in their
[ __ ] bartering relationships it's on
and let the real work comes when you get
ready to go to trial if you're not going
to trial
it's like I'm coming now my okay look
Lee [ __ ] do you take yours to trial
[Music]
taking my the trial they started with
1999 I said [ __ ] you I went I was in law
library I wanted to see what what did my
stuff started
what does the statute of limitations of
margin like yo where do I start cuz you
know different different possessions
different cases they have different my
like you would get caught with a certain
amount of possession is one thing versus
a delivery in a conspiracy conspiracy
starts at 20 delivery starts at 15
possession starts at 5 so I'm trying to
determine I really wanted to go in there
and telling people that I I was in
possession of 5 kilo the dope like I was
a smoker and my tough one to sell my
attorneys I
fight so you want me to tell him that
you were using [ __ ] you don't hate me I
gotta have it
I got it I got a bad habit he's like now
it's gonna be a delivery delivery of
controlled substance now and I found
delivery sales yeah say ourselves
delivery okay yeah possession you use a
you know something come in here right
now I got a baggie with an ounce of coke
with nothing wrapped its possession if
they come in and I got a scale and a
couple Bendel's even if there's none in
them then they get me on delivery
deliver conspiracy is if it's me you and
Lee if Lee gets the kilo and he gives a
we chopped it three ways and then not
that's conspiracy when it's a network of
people and conspiracy to deliver to
trolls
yes that's a [ __ ] right here I
had kidnapping one and kidnapping two
and aggravated robbery second-degree
burglary and then they threw it they
hauled crime of violence in that if you
get convicted they W sex so it's times
two so I had to think hard on this I'm
gonna see the guy kidnapped Saturday
night in Tucson the guy I kidnapped in
1988 87 he's coming to the show Saturday
night in Tucson this Saturday hysterical
he's been waiting for the last month
he's been calling me three times a week
and I won't answer his call to torture
you know because he didn't show up to
Tempe last year so I've been answering
the phone he finally hit me up on
Facebook
he said [ __ ] you coming to
Tucson I'm coming so the dude I
kidnapped in 1987 will be in the show in
Tucson this weekend so you in Tucson
yeah how crazy is that dawg that's crazy
so for me I knew he was a loose cannon
then he was gonna disappear so that's
why I kept postponing it I kept paying
my turn to push it back because the
victim would disappear eventually he
would even move to Mexico and then
there'd be no [ __ ] court now he showed
up they didn't let him testify though
because he had robbed the hospital
he jumped on this muff I got a DUI cut
his head open they took him to the
hospital while he was in the hospital he
broke into the pharmacy took the liquid
cocaine and a bunch of pills and jumped
out the [ __ ] window and then
didn't show up for court and had a
warrant out for his arrest when I
kidnapped him he had a warrant out for
his arrest so do you understand if they
would have relied on this yeah if I
would have taken up the trial it would
have been close close close too close to
risk forty-four eight years over oh yeah
it's in close I just almost got jury
duty and being seeing what the kind of
people they depict like this people who
just get bad luck like they've gotten
jury duty four times and like they're in
charge of your life that's like it
almost makes more sense to just have the
judge do it because at least they're
supposedly smart the people who I was in
the room with for jury duty
and terrified me like the thing that
they were in charge of someone's life
yeah yes it's a big thing people being
there wanting to go not let not listen
to all the evidence there's a man we
have we have a decline in educational
population so now they if you getting
picked you're getting judged by these
people these people these new people
become here jury the same people who
can't pay attention without they funny
got a small window over didn't smile I
think Kim Kardashian a good singer yeah
nationally great singer and she's a
public figure for the world so these are
the people who like yes I would like to
hear all the facts know this thing we do
is them and we in a tight spot I
remember the first because he Tidwell
got arrested first he got caught with
Vela in the trunk of the car so he got
the public attorney so when I walked in
there I knew exactly that's beautiful
for me because now I can't get a public
to turn
I gotta get a court-appointed real
[ __ ] attorney and the state
pays him because of a public attorney
handles maybe it's conflict of interest
there's when you get involved with two
or three people you shut your mouth
until you find that one guy got a public
attorney let them get the public
attorney you're gonna go over to we're
[ __ ] the church a real and I
want with a blank dude
his name was sunny flowers that was his
real name but he was black only in skin
color his soul was whiter than white and
he was in there selling my [ __ ] soul
and I'm gonna be called me a week after
I bail is that good news
we've gotten you a great deal it's nine
years and now honey goes and you're
bleeding - kidnapping - I don't mind mr.
flowers are you [ __ ] crazy and he
goes I think it's a great deal for you
you're nine years it's perfect for what
you doing well there's no violence they
got no proof but I was just buying time
I was just trying to get all my money
you know they get a real return so I was
just trying to get my [ __ ] in order to
get a real attorney now that one in
there started like a fake argument with
them because you can't tell them you
don't understand my grandmother was the
first black woman to ever graduate see
you both and I'm like you don't
understand I don't give a [ __ ] I'm gonna
get [ __ ] lynch mob than this
[ __ ] you taught me about your
[ __ ] grandmother I don't wanna hear
about your [ __ ] grandmother one more
goddamn time
nobody talks about my grandmother you
know you'll never be a Boy Scout all
this [ __ ] I mean he threw me out he
wrote a letter to the judge and then I
had to go see the judge I never forget
this I had snorted I must have started
nine eight balls on a Sunday night and I
had to see the judge at 10:00 the more
that one in there sweating bullets Holly
I know you've gone through this I go in
there I forget what the judges name was
he was bald he was a little bit of a
hard-on and I went in there and had
explained my situation he goes what
happened like I think we didn't come to
an agreement he goes mr. Diaz I want you
to get sentence and I know listen I
wasn't getting along amigos are you have
14 days to get new counsel and come in
here like okay thank you your honor
I think this by the way before you go
please go on my chambers and check with
my clerk for a date I've been to court a
thousand times that was [ __ ] weird
Ollie hmm before you leave call my
chambers this isn't fun everybody he
goes go outside and go in the first
office and check with my clerk for a
date for two weeks I say something don't
sound right I was by myself
I had no attorney with me so I walk out
he said glad that way that walk out and
I go in there I want to open up as a
lady there and she goes Hosea my wish
just hold on one second she opened up
the door and two feds came out like mr.
Diaz were [ __ ] such and such well
from [ __ ] the DEA and this is County
from Aspen and they started showing me
pictures of me on the balcony show me
pictures of me in a car showing me
pictures of me giving a guy like a
package and they were watching me up at
Aspen and they're like this is how you
could take care of this whole deal
we commend all they said to me if you
give us your dealer and Aspen will make
this situation go away and we promise
you you're doing amount of minimal time
I'm like so wait a second what you
trying to tell me is I'm gonna sell
myself and I still got to do time so I
thought about it first and if you know
anything about me you know I had to [ __ ]
with them a little bit
I had to [ __ ] with them a little bit
I took the dudes collar so I'll get back
to you and then I will call them like
every four days listen I seen a license
plate a six to six I know something is
busted my balls like if there was a drug
dealer that I owed money tip I would
call this [ __ ] and say like I
just seen a suspicious thing or my
neighborhood with this count you know I
wouldn't say that the nut you're about
to go to jail twice please you know me
dog I don't give a [ __ ] I could go on
for you
years tortured a cop the guy had a cop
that was so mad at me I Lisa deep this
[ __ ] tried to crack this coconut
that he showed up on my wife's ID for
the divorce hearing that's how you said
you Imogene I Dream of Jeannie it's not
about a white dude with a genie it's
about a white dude another white dude
with torture made you bellows they just
torch him he'd walk into an office and
having an orgy then he goes through a
portal he comes back and they're really
a bakery I had this cop I had this cop
that dude just retired that dude just
retired I would still send him flowers
I was Valentine's cards I was selling
Christmas cards I sent that [ __ ]
Christmas cards five years after they I
got out of prison because I know he
hated me so much man so why are you
because [ __ ] him because I hate him I
want him to [ __ ] go to his grave
thinking about how much he [ __ ] hated
and how he couldn't do dick to me cuz he
was key kept telling me anything you got
to do 50 [ __ ] years I made sure of it
and I'm my dog cop on you I tortured
that one of our golly I told him
remember I do start on me for a credit
card fraud
he stopped throw me an 85 when he was a
patrolman he thought he was [ __ ]
snoop snoop I was I got burglarized the
mall with a credit card and then my
stupid Cuban I yeah I went to the mall
first looking for a job story it's
amazing that he's free I terrorized this
mall first looking for a job and when I
didn't get the job nobody would give me
a job I took a credit card
like ten credit cards just destroyed
that long but I wanted to that mall when
they walked into the RadioShack do you
know I picked up a CD player one of
those DVD players wrap the wire around
you know how they unplugged
yeah it was a sample [ __ ] thing and
walked out of there with the sample I
destroyed this mall they were not ready
for Joe Diaz
but I thought method um with the credit
card I bought something every [ __ ]
stolen that more the small was three
floors I spent money and every for every
store in that mall I kept throwing the
cards away and taking them and going
back i tormented this mall
I had to merchandise all over that
[ __ ] apartment the one day I'm
working I got a call from full block and
they want to hire me in that mall in
that mall so I take the job of foot lock
with my stupid Cuban ass I'm 21 years
old and I have a footlocker robbing up a
storm right robbing like a [ __ ]
and one day this Chinese family comes in
winging em hopes the Chinese New Year
envelopes and they trying on shoes and
I'm looking at that envelope and [ __ ]
and all these Chinese people trying on
shoes I clipped the envelope and put it
in my pants it had to be like [ __ ] I
don't know $2,000 $3,000 I went right in
the back of the place and I opened up a
bag of size 13 sneakers and I put the
envelope inside the sneaker and I went
back up I just had a weird feeling and
when they went to pay for the sneakers
only what happened to the emboss our
envelope is lost what happened I'm
starting to feel bad the kids are crying
and [ __ ] I'm like oh I'm gonna go to
hell for this an awesome they leave they
came back an hour later with the cops we
know for a fact when we came in here we
had that [ __ ] envelope so either
somebody stole or somebody who works
here story there was like three of us
and I'm like dog none of us took it
either you dropped it you know what that
cop kept looking at me weird and two
days later that [ __ ] comes back
in the hood so I talk to you for a
second he goes I just got a report that
there's a guy that matches your
description that bought a bunch of
jewelry whatever so we're waiting for
the cameras to come back is this you you
might as well turn yourself in now this
[ __ ] came every 7 days he came
in for five days with that same story
every day coming I know mr. Diaz have
you decided to turn yourself in yeah you
know we got the sizes of the pants and
stuff right you know we're gonna hang
the sign you know
I don't know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about they kept coming to
footlocker coming a footlocker
then Sunday night the [ __ ]
knocking on my door he's like you know
we're gonna come back here and arrest
you tomorrow we can make this a lot
easier I'm like dog you could arrest me
you wouldn't be here talking this [ __ ]
now get the [ __ ] off my stoop then that
night I left for San Francisco let him
come back for like two years that was in
August of 85 Holly do you know when I
kidnapped that [ __ ] November of
87 you know I turned myself into that
dude another cop and he never remembered
Holly he never he kept looking at me
like he knew me from somewhere and every
time I go to court he'd be looking at me
and I'm like what is this fool gonna
remember but I was the credit-card
bandit when he the polder card had a
ball to credit card board the boat a
credit card man when is he gonna [ __ ]
realize now that dude he's gonna be
sitting up when they just don't pop into
his head like something that you came
remember well joy dears
no I was at the Comedy Works two years
ago and the feature that opened for me
was a boulder cop and I said to him I
asked him I said this is that cop still
there and he goes yeah I'll ask him
about you oh I go send them my love cuz
I always send him Christmas cards at the
police station so I sent him [ __ ]
[ __ ] the years I think I haven't sent
them anything like 12 years 13 years I
think I sent them something with the
longest yarn go [ __ ] yourself what have
you done with your life he's [ __ ] the
flatfoot [ __ ] Here I am busting
out without him saying how you like me
now I said from the trading card do you
they have these trading cards and I sent
it to him do you have a problem with
police I don't actually no not at all
all right never in my life Pacific not a
law I don't like I like when a cop is a
cop I like when the cop talks to me from
the heart and I talk back to him from
the heart I hated cops like him because
they really thought they were making a
difference I don't want you to be a cop
that thinks you're making a dick
should I make the difference you're not
really making with them you going after
when you watch those Pablo Escobar's and
you watch them cheer and [ __ ] I look at
you and I feel bad for you because you
just plug them one hole in the wall you
don't see that you just give it another
guy a [ __ ] light Lea my mom shut the
[ __ ] up you can act like that Wow yeah
we got him you know that [ __ ] has always
killed me those gung-ho cops they bother
me but cops are the cops it's like the
cops that pulled us over that night
right I'm all hyper man on the steering
wheel I never had a problem with a cop
other than that cop let me tell you
something I got a rest of the time I
don't warrant I got arrested on a
possession of stolen tools thing and I
had a warrant in Bergen County the cop
that drove me from Tenafly to bergen
county jail stopped and got me Chinese
food that's how good I am around cops I
tell them the truth my brother's a cop
I admire you guys you guys are doing a
job and I [ __ ] up that's the truth too
by the time yeah I got no beef with
chops I don't want to shoot a cop I got
nothing against cops cop sir
I give them my that's why I don't like
this [ __ ] that's going on with cops
shooting people and I've always said it
stopped but the shooting the black
people stop if you're them I tell you
what's gonna happen you're gonna get
five angry brothers that all trained
Special Forces they're all gonna start
talking one night and they're gonna
start sniper in the [ __ ] city that's
gonna happen but all it takes is two
brothers to get together and say this
shit's gonna end call it the Black
Panthers reprogrammed reboot call it the
Black Panthers reboot and that's what's
gonna happen I'm no [ __ ] Swami from
salamé
but it don't take even being a genius to
know that one day one brother he's gonna
call his cousin go hey they just shot
out a little cousin in Memphis it's just
gonna stop let's go down to Memphis
let's get all our little army buddies to
get all our little black sniper friends
and let's go picking off [ __ ]
cops on Main Street
we'll pick off a white cop a day until
the [ __ ] violence ends this is gonna
happen someday
it may not be tomorrow it may not be in
ten years but someday this is gonna
happen because this keeps happening and
people don't understand people
understand and it's gonna take one angry
do one too [ __ ] [ __ ] to say you
know what I know how to [ __ ] shoot I
to shoot I could outshoot Lee Harvey
Oswald yes I tried listen you know this
football thing I was talking about was
that that [ __ ] camera Nikki man no no
no no no I was the [ __ ] about this thing
about the city I was telling my CTE oh
yeah then now this since white kids are
not playing football no more more and
more like more blacks are going to
Princeton now like they're allowing it
now like [ __ ] it we don't give a [ __ ] we
need football because the n-c-double-a
spends more on football scholarships
then all of the sports combined did you
know that yep then all of the sports
combined then what makes the most money
the n-c-double-a spends on [ __ ]
football and now because of this white
kid not playing football [ __ ]
that means more black kids and Puerto
Ricans are gonna be going through the
school that you worked hard to [ __ ]
get into right and now parents are
[ __ ] pissed this is what this whole
thing of real sports is about that
parents are like wait a second you're
letting these kids are not [ __ ]
school we pay 40 grand a year well
that's also kind of racist that's very
racist is then they're like something
like what you telling me is that when
they relax and water Ricans away from
you well then sometimes they pay to just
get in like like they'll pay just to oh
I'll donate to get a library but they
didn't deserve to get in Harvard that's
happening - yeah which is pretty crazy
well can you guys explain the the no
snitching thinking I mean obviously I've
everyone's been told not to
that's a cattle tale but then like this
thing is happening with this rapper
right now with Snoop Dogg they're
getting mad like this rapper I had a
whole like 40 years of possible prison
time and now he's gonna get probation
for for ratting and everyone to me if I
was gonna go to jail I like it it'd be
like yeah maybe I'm like I can see where
tattling is like okay I'm not gonna go
to jail now but is it something
different like what how come people take
it so seriously it's um
it's a code it's a culture thing and
they were no snitching is don't know but
I really won't live under that they
think they do but
you you actually don't in those days or
over that's when me and with me and
though that's when when the streets took
care of itself and things would come
around I don't think that there's been
an actual no snitching situation shoot
man since before Kobe Bryant like Kobe
Bryant snitched on Shaq al Sharpton was
a fan telling on people it is out man
out so I think everybody snitched
nowadays buddy Bulger was a snitch for
Whitey Bulger was a huge snitch Mike was
a huge snitch for years like for the
face of man I don't that's that's
something I don't know man here's what
my take on it I got to takes honest I
was raised in the house that you want a
lot to say that my mother exposed me to
everything at an early age I know my
mother did I know what the numbers were
I know what drugs were I was exposed
early anything my first raid I was five
when they raided my mother's house on
89th Street so at that age my mother
would already tell me in Spanish
Kyah that I walk I know they're not no
they're not shut your mouth so it's like
I remember still being like eight and
being on 205 West 88th Street and a beat
cop came up to me and told me to scrub
something off the floor and I told him
why would i scrub it off if I didn't do
it we got into like a very mild
conversation and my stepfather had
already married my mother and he would
talk to me and I remember him walking
towards me and he looked at me in
Spanish he's a nobody and I tell people
you know I don't say nothing to him you
know so I was always raised to keep my
[ __ ] mouth shut I came from a
neighborhood where where I play that my
godmothers house you couldn't be a
snitch and then when I moved to Jersey
you couldn't be a snitch when you get
arrested the first thing you do is to
keep your mouth shut you don't know
nothing now I was in a situation where I
was facing jail time they came to me and
asked me to make make buys or whatever
listen I'd rather
[ __ ] stabbed myself in my heart I can
never ever ever do that
now there's something else you asking me
about snitching I'm not a snitch I don't
know nothing I don't know you know what
the [ __ ] you're talking about if you're
involved you do your time and you keep
you're not sure it's not what people
think it's what you know character is
what [ __ ] you know don't let my
character ruin my destiny and characters
what you do with nobody else is around
that's why you don't snitch now if I'm a
big volume drug dealer if I make a half
a million a year on coke half a million
a year on gambling a half a million a
year on hot stuff a half million
construction everybody is always trying
to shoot you down so number one for you
to get ahead and to get up in that level
you have some dirty cops I was a punk
drug dealer and I had dirty cops
I had a cop that would give me all the
guns he count biscayne it for coke so
anyhow I tell him anyhow gun get 200
cash I was just shipping back east I
remember still this guy coming to my
house at 2:00 in the morning on duty
with his jaw gone from side to side this
I spending in this having him asking me
for a gram of coke now when you're in
that position there when you're in the
million dollar game okay
there's gonna be times like Michael dot
like Michael dad told me a story one
time I told my wasn't gonna bode those
podcasts which I still owe an appearance
on and he goes on saying that in the
boat that you know me because one time
bo and his crew were about to arrest
somebody and we saw the paperwork and we
went over there and robbed the guys
drugs someone bo got over there with the
rest of the cops all the drugs were gone
and bo knew it was us okay when you're
making a half a million dollars a year
from drugs the last thing you need is
Ali Siddiq said to shop over that that
funeral parlor
especially if I'm right here I need a
lead to get with his [ __ ] friends
jumping up and down with rap music and
[ __ ] cars at night and we're trying
to sell a million dollars here I got a
cop in my pocket I'll tell him to go
over and talk to Ali go
bah stylee shut him down over there
because he's making a racket towards my
business that's part of business okay
that's not called the that's that's part
of business that's part of business I'll
ease God assistant and I went to a club
one night and I called her a [ __ ]
[ __ ] or whatever ally knows me ally
knows me we're friends he knows I'm a
drug dealer
you know I know polishing me whatever
you know what he might just by mistake
put him out to coke in my car make me
get pulled over that's not a rat that's
part of doing Street that's Street
business that's Street business that's
that's part of going even Danny's that's
part of getting mixed up in the [ __ ]
game if you're a drug-dealing you have
any cloud or a numbers operator or
anything you have a cop on your payroll
you have a couple cops on their payroll
may have his and they'll come to you and
say listen we just busted through dude
alley and he's down there right like
cops work like that too so I already
know so I'll call the king of the
[ __ ] brothers and go hey if you got
something going out I'll leave
disconnect because he's in there rat now
I just want myself a favor with the
brothers right now I just want myself a
favor with the brothers cuz I leaves
running with the brothers over on 88th
Street now I go over there and tell him
hey I leave red how do you know because
he's in there singing the blues whose
copernicus me how do you know why I tell
you that [ __ ] I'll lead you rat on
copernicus now they owe me a solid so
it's all on the street it's all about
solids so is it more of it's not that
your tatting is that you're dealing with
the cops yes it's a you you've made them
a partner and now they're your partner
you know uh you want to become a drug
dealer right right they did this to my
friends one time like they did this to
Kurt and and and uh Danny be okay they
[ __ ] went and they made it so you I
come to you and I go Lee I don't know
anybody in Boston can you sell me coke
and boss me like yeah sure I'll make a
phone call for you so I'll take thirty
thousand cash and when I get to Boston
you'll call a drug deal and say Jodie is
there the Ace Hotel rules
what 30 to go over any time you got a
kilo of coke just robbed they'll set you
up that way so you use cops as a setup
also dama well for me to go into
someplace and then say to me while
you're looking at 20 years right on
somebody they gave me the opportunity in
87 I could have rather Dom the people
from Aspen they came in and gave me the
pictures
all I had to tell them was three names
and I was like for what what's the sense
I'm gonna know I'm gonna [ __ ] though
I I guess this is probably why I never
would have made it as a criminal like
it's just it's a it's a whole different
world to me like it's crazy to me that
you would you spent years robbing drug
dealers and taking all their money but
we won't read them out like there's just
certain lines you don't cross like yes
and I guess it makes sense but it's like
[ __ ] think I didn't get into then you
have to watch your back and you got to
know who you the animal you're dealing
with this and you got to know what their
ammunition is and who they got on the
payroll and cuz you never know you know
not every cop is a decent individual
there's some cops are there out there
you you read about it every week cops
get duis cop they have faults too right
and they're sinners also they have
faults also so they get hooked on coke
being on the job yeah well don't don't
please have like a place like they call
it the way it's just something it's like
a rehab well they're undercover cops
they do is yeah they have they've always
had one of those where you you [ __ ]
go to one thing you get picked up on a
conspiracy right right and here's how we
hang out with Joe Diaz for two [ __ ]
years every little every bump I'll he
does Joe Diaz does a bump on them every
[ __ ] bump cuz I don't know by you you
know my only a Miami Vice
did you sell a kilo to a [ __ ]
I've never seen him do a bump in front
that's only a Miami Vice and the
[ __ ] comes with a blue tube and
test the coke and shakes it and looks to
see if the coke is yella
everybody I did business we kind of put
a [ __ ] finger nail in there and do
two lines in front of me I gotta see you
do those two lines or when I talk it
but when I got locked up when I first
got locked up I got locked up in a Fed
place and there were [ __ ] and
there was a dude man I became friends
with that told me write up that he
called a conspiracy case and that the
[ __ ] three is he goes listen every
time I shot this guy shot with me I
think it was during the conspiracy case
they separated us alibi he goes I
finally made bail after a month and a
half and at the trial the guy walked in
he goes I couldn't believe it
he goes my jaw dropped he goes this guy
had done [ __ ] him
they were shootin coke he goes for every
time I shot this [ __ ] shot his
vein there's no way they're gonna gain
your trust unless they're there with you
snorting I know a guy when I was at the
car wash the undercover cops would get
their car washed there so I got to see
what all the cars look like and they
were all repo'd cars like the mayor
arrest dolly you know he's got coconut
car if he's over a state jurisdiction
there ought to take the car I won't take
the car from Texas and bring it up to
Colorado and give it to the undercover
units there and the cars in Colorado
will ship to Houston so the Houston drug
dealers won't know him there it's very
slick it's very slick a guy that's a cop
in in North Hollywood and becomes an
undercover cop in North Hollywood
doesn't do arrests in North Hollywood he
goes to Redondo Beach because nobody
knows him right so as a criminal do you
ever trust any any other criminal like
Jimmy it seems like you can't yes I
trust criminals more than I trust these
[ __ ] people that tell you how nice
they are and how because what a criminal
I know where I stand even though they
have undercover cops I know where I
stand with a criminal I know when a guy
who goes bad I know so I stay the [ __ ]
away from him but I had more luck with
criminals that I do I'm not pointing out
alley I'm just pointing out the air
saying I am I've always done better
because I know where they stand I know
what to look for he's a [ __ ] stick of
God now you deal with the it's
no words my feelings law regular people
when a criminal does something to me my
feelings don't get hurt because I knew
that he was a criminal okay when one is
some idiot promoter tries to when I call
him and tell him I want to do ten
minutes and he puts my picture up and
and tries to make money off me that's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] move right there that's a
guy that doesn't know I was a criminal
for 20 [ __ ] years and so there's
people in the sneaky people they pissed
me the [ __ ] off more than criminals
because when the criminal burns me I
know where I stood I'd done with a
criminal that's what you get right you
know when you [ __ ] it's like Don King
Don King was a criminal but you know you
stood you knew when you hugged Don King
he was gonna [ __ ] rape you in the ass
eventually somewhere hey don't when you
hug Don King if you're making ten
million you better know Don King's
getting a million of that somewhere
somewhere Don King's getting a million
on the ticket sales the added charge is
somewhere Don King ain't there smiling
but when you hugged him and you got in
bed with him you knew where you stood
there's people that you do that with
then they stab you and you go Jesus
Christ those are the people that really
[ __ ] pissed me off
if Don King came to me right now and he
said I want to promote your new CD and
he made the number sound right I would
do it with Don King cuz I know he's
gonna rub but he's gonna get the CD and
I'm gonna make a half a million dollars
with him because he's a [ __ ] thief he
knows how to go in there shake
[ __ ] down he'll go down on me
but put the album in here I'll stab you
in the [ __ ] neck he'll open doors
nobody else could open do you understand
me so you give him this take and I said
he made Mike Tyson a [ __ ] bazillion
it okay so but so did if the
[ __ ] is I know how many people
come to us and they have a [ __ ]
hidden agenda Oh everybody's got a
hidden agenda specially in this [ __ ]
town yeah I had a guy go off on me
outline six months ago because he wanted
a career he wanted to help with his
career and I wouldn't give it to him so
he went off online about where is that
guy today he ain't doing comedy cuz he
was looking for his hand/eye I see them
coming before they get here because I
know what it is to love comedy I know
what it is to be a criminal I know what
it is to really
copy someone you you just you know ask
hacking around like a spies
you know insane and spitting [ __ ] out I
know you're not putting the work in we
know when you're putting the [ __ ]
working where is he today God God
because he was looking for a [ __ ]
handout
yeah but he made me seem like the bad
guy I'm not the bad guy I help all my
[ __ ] colleagues I try to help you as
much help as you deserve just as you
stroll into town and you know yeah you
know I want to be your friend that don't
work that way it's the same way and
exactly I think this is what it is
people who love it like like me I'm I'm
dying asleep right now some polygon J so
I can't do my job tonight what's ours I
show tonight man ain't Clarke I'm glad
you told me
eight o'clock what you got coming up
Olly
um this weekend I am actually in DC and
DC improv I'm recording my album that's
one of the best places in the world to
record a new record Noblet yeah
800-pound gorilla yeah yeah that's a
great [ __ ] place that's a great place
to shoot that so I'm I'm coming to
Houston though I heard March 7th I heard
March 7th through the night when I'm
around well you um Thursday Friday
Saturday it's gonna be bananas I can't
wait I can't wait it's been a long time
since yeah yeah two years I tried to
space it out yeah I trying to hit Austin
one year I didn't like to do a huge
priority ain't there no more what do the
little dudes a little perverted dude the
manager about your thing to get him out
of there cuz he was a creepy
[ __ ]
I know he thought but Houston's me you
know I love that [ __ ] place with all
my life yeah price to gain some weight
down there dawg
I don't know you stay so skinny and good
limit I don't eat no [ __ ] they'd be
serving because I I want to it smell so
good you know what they've you know much
they want for gumbo in here at the
barbecue joint $1,000 $1,000 for a
[ __ ] bowl
what is it nice to stuff oh happy eight
eight thousand twenty one dollars for a
ball of [ __ ] up
I'm gonna be in Vegas this Friday Friday
week 8 Quigley and Saturday Tucson
Arizona with my man Katt Vela at the Fox
Tita Holly I want to thank you for
coming on I'm sorry you're tired and
whatever but it's always a pleasure to
see you
now this is totally my father public
enemy number one I still love you to
death
this is totally my fault come on
whatever the [ __ ] you want every year in
town I'm trying to I'm trying to get the
complete the ultimate trifecta do re
first yours Joe's in Tom's girl and I
think I'll be good on all the podcasts
are you doing the podcast this week is
just you man you don't want to do all
your doing our reason F this is just you
cuz Bert's in town too Bert will be
there too like I was talking to him
tonight you know I'm happy to be there
tonight
that's about the whole this is not
happening team under the new story but
unnamed storytellers will you'll be down
there doing the open mic officer littles
dad
his dad's probably sleeping on the
sleeping pill give him a bong head of
sleep until he's just hanging out he's
done he's dog you thought he gave my gig
you might done an edible he gave my dad
an edible every time and it gets he just
he just in outer space Oxnard last 65
[ __ ] years oh he would have
done the answer to that I got some acid
he was all over he was he was excited at
least a dick great to see you thank you
very much for coming on the show man
don't forget you [ __ ] I'll see
you this weekend Tucson Las Vegas Friday
night Viva I love you guys I want to
thank Ali I want to thank the
[ __ ] but most importantly I
want to thank you guys for always
supporting the podcast and listening
well I gotta talk to you about something
right one of the most important things
we do for our health every day is
brushing our teeth yet most of us don't
do it properly quip is a better electric
toothbrush created by dentists and
designers quip was designed to make
brushing your teeth more simple
affordable and even enjoyable all right
me I love it
and I told you why when we started
number one I love traveling with it it's
easy to put away the batteries
thing number two I love the little
vibrator for you to let you know or we
tell you seconds to switch
it's got sensitive sonic vibrations
gentle enough on your sensitive gums
people brush too hard and someone like
the two pressures are too abrasive not
quit it's got a built-in two-minute
timer that pulses every 30 seconds to
remind you when to switch and the
helping guide to full and even clean Y
up to 90% of us don't brush for a full
two minutes or don't even clean evenly a
multi-use cover mounts to your mirror
and unmount to slide over the bristles
for on-the-go brushing don't let you
know all this stuff Claudia stinks this
makes traveling when electric toothbrush
even easier grip doesn't require a
clunky charger and it runs for three
months on one charge three months that
means if I put it in May you know me I
always recharge but I'm just letting you
know if you're bad will remember in
three months on one charge three out of
four of us will use two brushes the
bristles are all worn out or ineffective
qyp is one of the first electric
toothbrushes that is accepted by the
American Dental Association has
thousands of verified five-star reviews
so do me a favor
I love quit that's why I love them now
they're backed over by 20,000 dental
professional whip starts at $25 and if
you go to get quick calm right now /
Joey right now you'll get your first
real pill refill pack for free with the
quip electric toothbrush that's right go
to get quick calm / Joey right now and
you'll get the first refill pack for
free
that's your first refill pack for free
at get quick calm / Joey listen it's
February 21st and you stopped and got
your life together you made all these
notes you're gonna do this you're gonna
do that you're gonna help that you're
gonna work out you're gonna go you
haven't done anything you did it for
three days then you got sick and tired
you're not taking something wish you're
not drinking a little protein powder you
want to get this whole thing resolved go
to Holland calm right now they're the
Masters of the bed show that Mexican
chocolate protein father is tremendous
okay the one before it the cocoa was
tremendous also you got shrimp tank you
got shrimp export
you got shoot a commune and you got the
leader alpha brain nootropics to help
you think clear and then focus then they
got a hundred percent money-back
guarantee and you keep the product
that's how much they believe in alpha
brain serve your little clowny if your
little BOTS alpha brain might be for you
but it all starts by you going
tonic time you see some on the way that
you're checking that you're pressing
Church you get 10% off deliver it right
to your house all right who takes care
you Joey
nobody I'm giving you electric
toothbrush refills and I'm letting you
know about on it I'm as good as it gets
don't forget about me I love you guys
I'll see you guys Monday morning tip top
Magoo ready to go the rest he is I'll
see you in Vegas and the other half of
you [ __ ] I'll see fat the Fox
Theatre in Tucson with my man Kent Vela
on the drums have a great weekend
they're rightly kick this [ __ ] mule